hi there Steve Kaufman here I want to
talk a little bit about Latta an email
from a person who reads my blog the
latest on language and that was Jeff and
he said where do I stand on the relative
importance of the input hypothesis which
is crashing and something called the
interaction hypothesis can you achieve
fluency based on input alone um well I
don't know you know what trying to hide
that light again
I don't know what crashing actually says
on this but to me and I have said this
before to become fluent you have to
speak and you have to speak a lot you
have to interact a lot so there is no
question in my mind that input alone
will not take you to fluency what I have
said though is that input and a great
emphasis on input has a number of
tremendous advantages it is very
effective it is inexpensive you don't
have to depend on somebody else being
willing to talk to you you can build up
your capability in the language through
a lot of listening and reading and
vocabulary accumulation all of which is
going to make it easier for you to
interact with people but that does not
mean that that's the only thing you do
you know whenever I have the opportunity
I interact but if I don't have that
opportunity if I'm not living in the
country where the language is spoken if
I don't have friends and if I don't want
to pay for a teacher I'm happy to spend
a lot of time on input which is what I
have done with Russia but absolutely I
know that to achieve a higher level in
my spoken Russian
I have to interact I have to talk to
people so yeah I mean you can't just get
there on input alone however and this is
where I had my disagreement with our
friend Benny the Irish polyglot you
don't need to speak you don't need to
speak especially in the beginning stages
and I find that it's preferable to put
most of my effort into input activity at
the beginning so that even if I am
speaking to people I might speak to
people for 10% of the time but spent 90%
of my time initially getting the
language in me I also believe that there
is no need to worry about one's
performance early or really at any time
we are not performing we are
communicating so worrying about you know
how well we pronounce or pitch in
Japanese or all these things are just
unnecessary burdens worrying about the
other getting the grammar correct at
early stages these are all unnecessary
burdens it is quite sufficient to focus
on input build up your vocabulary I mean
as an example I'm now going back to
reading Anna Karenina in Russian when I
was fighting my way through it a couple
of years ago on link there were 50% or
more words that were new to me today I
go there I open up a chapter of Anna
Karenina in link there's 10% new words
that includes names that includes
different forms of words that I already
know so there's relatively few words
there that I don't know now some of the
words that I supposedly know according
to link that are all highlighted in
yellow I may refresh them but basically
I know I'm now in a situation where I
can read Anna Karenina in Russian and I
know 95% of the words so how well do I
speak Russian not as well as I read it
or as I can understand what I listen to
if I want to get my Russian up to a
higher level I've got to surround myself
with people who's being Russian but this
is difficult to do here in bankbook and
and
occasionally I'll talk to people again
our tutors at link which is good and
it's particularly good for identifying
gaps things that I need to work on if I
had the willpower to write more often
that's also very good but I know that if
I went to Russia for three months now
I would significantly improve my Russian
if I spoke to people if I went there as
a beginner bene style uhm I would still
have to spend most of my time on input
because just talking to people is not
going to bring me the vocabulary that I
need and ultimately and this gets back
to this discussion about pitch we had
this person worrying about pitch in
Japanese and he wrote something on our
forum and to me it was obvious that he
didn't have the vocabulary he didn't
have the words so focus on getting the
words and everything else is going to
fall into place
so yeah absolutely in fact the way I
look at you know the way we acquire
languages it's not something that we're
putting building blocks one on top of
the other and building this knowledge of
the language that we study chapter one
and we know everything in Chapter one
and then we do chapter two and we know
everything in Chapter two it doesn't
work that way it's I've described it as
walking in the fog and the fog is slowly
dissipating or it's like a jigsaw puzzle
and the more of the pieces of the puzzle
that come together the more other things
start to become clear and it's not
obvious when these different pieces of
the puzzle are going to come together so
we just continue and we speak can we
listen and we read we do things and and
we get interested in different things at
different times I now find that I'm much
better able to focus on the cases of
Russian because I have so much
vocabulary and I've read the
explanations a few times and I've tried
to focus on the tense on the case
endings a few times and I've reviewed
the tables a few times and slowly slowly
slowly these things start to come
together and so I am more and more keen
to use the language so I'm ready for it
so
what you want to do at different times
but you're ready to do at different
times it's all going to vary as the
pieces of the jigsaw puzzle come
together and certainly a big part of
achieving genuine fluency is speaking
and speaking a lot like we're in you're
in a situation say you go to the country
or you're with people and you're talking
for hours in the language now in order
to talk for hours in the language you
have to have a lot of vocabulary and
that doesn't come from just talking
people that comes from listening and
reading so I guess in conclusion I think
that input is tremendously powerful in
that it's easy to do on our iPods
reading books it's inexpensive is it's
enriching it's developing our potential
but in order to finally realize that
potential you definitely need to start
to interact to write and speak and you
need to write a speak a lot okay so if
the question is is it the input
hypothesis or the interaction hypothesis
I would say at the end of the day it's
the interaction hypothesis but for a
long period in the initial stage it's
the input approach and more than
anything else it's the enjoyment
hypothesis people should do what they
like to do and not get impatient not get
frustrated not put unnecessary pressure
on themselves worrying about pitch and
things like that
just enjoy the language enjoy
communicating and as you feel more and
more confident get out there and
interact with people so I hope that
answers Jeff's question and it was a
good excuse to do a video here bye for
now